au sein de la cloche cette pochette pour
déposer son cellulaire à l'entrée de la
classe se remplit à vue d'oeil la preuve
que les jeunes du secondaire sont
maintenant nombreux à avoir un téléphone
intelligent on sait qu'à travers les
années
la problématique touchant les
cellulaires a augmenté pour plusieurs
professeurs ces pochettes sont devenus
essentielles au bon fonctionnement de
leur classe selon la Fédération des
syndicats de l'enseignement 92% de ses
membres veulent interdire le cellulaire
en classe sauf dans le cadre d'activités
pédagogiques ce qu'on ne veut pas c'est
le cellulaire qui devient une diversion
la Fédération québécoise des directions
d'établissements d'enseignement et du
même avis une réglementation nationale
permettrait de soutenir les équipes
école car on ne la voit du ministre qui
s'ajoute à la nôtre ça devient une
réglementation qui est provinciale c'est
sûr que ça nous donne un coup de main
parce qu'on sait que tout le monde va
dans le même sens qu'on a l'appui du
ministère parce que bon vous le savez
des fois ça peut amener certaines
discussions avec des parents
actuellement chaque établissement est
dans certains cas chaque classe est
libre d'interdire ou non le téléphone
cellulaire ce qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité parmi les élèves je suis
pour qu'on réduise ou qu'on encadre plus
l'utilisation de téléphone en classe
mais pas pour qu'on l'enlève
complètement moi je pense que c'est une
mauvaise idée parce que des fois dans
des projets d'équipe ou
des fois quand on fait un travail toute
manière de base je pense des fois ça
peut être nous être utile je suis pas
contre parce que je pense quand même
génération qui est quand même addict au
téléphone puis que l'intérieur ça
pourrait aider certaines personnes qui
sont pas capables de s'encadrer seul une
spécialiste il met toutefois des nuances
le cri du coeur des enseignants est en
voie qui est envoyé il n'y a pas de
bannir le cellulaire mais bien de les
soutenir dans la gestion des appareils
personnels des élèves questionner sur la
possibilité d'interdire le téléphone
cellulaire en classe le bureau du
ministre de l'éducation d'y poursuivre
sa réflexion je suis ouvert à y
réfléchir ici Magalie Masson
Radio-Canada Québec